jo leute und herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten tenor in zweifel games seit
langem auf diesem kanal
es geht direkt überweisen dennis und
dave der ganzen action bronson und ja
ich habe wieder einen ganz guten anfang
sloot bekommen eisenachs und stein
schwer das kann sich sehen lassen und
ist genau es zu holen
joneleit unique haye die nämlich 14
wo bist du da jetzt gib mir deine girls
play golf have played display
ich will deine gold alter sterben
ja ich denke weiter geil
das war lustig rom ist sich im lilly
petrom banken sondern diesen typen
erzählen oder sogar nahe und keine
sicherheiten kürzlich retten kannst du
dich retten
unter den freunden alter was teilweise
versucht per post verpisst euch ich war
eine mikro dass es scheint wird es
wirklich so auf leute es gibt scheinbar
1000 mal mehr teams hier aufgaben also
frei hättest du gehst mich so an
es gibt aber so scheiße die teams aber
so richtig heiß für teams so und du bist
vielleicht mal drauf und ich war geboten
nein nein noch nicht sicher
mein leben ist wieder mal schalter
taster mich noch nie dass mir die
liebsten alimente herren und so erzählte
mein team partner getötet jetzt freue
ich mich nicht mehr jetzt nicht dass ich
dein stück building alter mann sich
täglich dafür nicht mehr ist er
gestorben ist gestorben verändern weil
der typ ist einfach gestorben
pienaar hat warum wir gerade gestorben
müssen die kommentare erklärt mir das
neue in der schlucht seiner ja ich habe
leider keine pfeile aber mache direkt
mal weiter
allerdings ihr sg auf burma ich ganz
ordentlich oder davon es bestimmt pro
euro hätten die axt durch mich dem
stellen sich falten
er macht das coupé die m in 10 15
sekunden den airplay ich bin ja ja ja
und was machen wir hier
wir haben eine fette party was ich
verbessern kann
ich schreibe ja und dann tom hardy wie
du willst dich schreibt meine kommentare
ob ich die rechtschreibkorrektur sie
diese korrektur auf kultur bei 32 ja ich
kenne dich rein gesteckt
ich habe am ende habe ich nicht mal
getroffen ärgerlich
wir sehen uns wieder und wieder
zu fressen das ist doch scheiße ich habe
ich habe in der holz axt ganz amt sonst
wird alles in allem ist nur für dich
alles nur für dich oh oh oh oh oh das
war gar nicht schlecht hier hast du bist
jetzt vielleicht holt mich verarschen
willst du mich verarscht eigentlich sind
ja bedeutet nicht nur zwei herzen
für mich ist dann ist da noch die haben
ja da ist es doch für auf damit ich kann
diesen schlag
ja ich will mir nicht
ob dein leben gerettet
hey hey danke ich getroffen wird eine 36
kotelett chili nicht alles ja ja ja ja
ja ja ja leute im einsatz hier
einsatzteams die sport ist im einsatz
ihr aber ja noch was wir machen wenn der
gegner kämpfen die alleine sind gehen
wir allein auf die drauf er das muss
sein riesiges loch aus
nur wenn ihr mehrere also wenn leute zu
zweit sind gehen wir zu zweit achten
drauf wenn wir zu dritt sind zu treten
und zu viel zu fett aber so nie mehr
gegner man als der letzte dingsda
aufbieten an dieser stelle vor dem
wetter besser hätten können der hat mir
gut gegeben
guter fight alter wissen gebracht ich
hab gedacht ich könnte ja von oben so
hasler kasten und so war nicht so drin
da kommt machen
da man den computer links helfen die
drauf los und gott was der minister darf
einiges los vor ihm
der eng mit dem bogen auf mich ja und
jetzt jetzt nicht vom charakters macht
ja dann mache ihn alleine kaputt ich
habe mich schon immer die feile in ein
alter wo ich muss ich muss erst mal ganz
was macht gewinnen herzen kommt von oben
nicht ob ich mag ihn von oben platzwarte
scheiße habe ich mich gehalten hast mir
überhaupt nicht getroffen
ich habe in zwei teile und noch zwei
hitzebeständig gegeben aber weg von den
spielen ich gehe den weg der ultra
schlecht getroffen
ich hab ihn zwei jetzt mit bogen gegeben
und zwei zum schwert warum der typ mann
das ist doch dave fast erstickt habe ich
feile gib mir mal ein paar pfeile ab da
habe ich mal okay okay jetzt ist ganz
klar nicht ich komme die nicht hochaltar
ich flippe aus bisschen schickte man
muss dem wasser von hoch glaube ich mal
alte wieder gelegt hat alte wieder
gelegt hat was war das schaulaufen der
lexus scheiße dummen alter alter kümmert
euch mal den kopf
tötet ihn kaputt
die nicht kriegt wir haben noch ein
federer der türkei reisen warum
ja okay ich habe direkt alter ist
einfach mein stein schule geschmissen
du wolltest du wieder die ecken ich weiß
du sagst deswegen sagst du scheiße was
hier kann es gibt nur noch die beiden
jetzt ja ich will das machen wir ja die
geraubten behindert
junge fallen ja das hier ist nicht
wohltäter games zwei bremst du kannst
weile haben heute kriegt die hälfte
meiner pfeile beziehungsweise die
kleinere hälfte des 9
ich würde gerne viereinhalb pfeile geben
aber okay insgesamt 321 was kommt schon
voll schlecht dafür schlecht ok und
jetzt glaubte alter der hundezählung was
dafür mut du willst du bist du ja es war
ja auch mal ganz so diese gefallen hat
einen daumen nach oben die an der
beschreibung dave und dennis und da will
ich sagen hat einen schönen tag macht
gut und schau